ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre la suite et la fin de la
discussion du projet de loi sur
l'immigration à mes côtés pour en parler
fabienne keller sénatrice ump du
bas-rhin bonjour alors malgré les
avancées du sénat sur ce texte
vous n'allez pas le voter est ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi je
suis très réservé sur ces textes
sécuritaires qui certes ont été adoucies
par le sénat mais qui ne respecte pas
des principes par exemple l'accueil des
étrangers malades c'est le droit
vraiment aux soins que la france a
toujours défendu je regrette les
restrictions qui sont désormais imposées
il en est de même pour cette idée de
retirer la nationalité en cas de délit
certes très grave mais la nationalité
elle n'est pas rétractable pour certains
alors qu'elle serait définitive pour
d'autres on n'a pas le droit d'avoir
deux conceptions du fait d'être français
le sénat a marqué sa différence il a eu
des débats de fond notamment hier soir
sur l'article 37 et la saisine du jld
donc dans la rétention des étrangers
ça ne vous satisfait pas je suis
heureuse que le sénat ait fait ce
travail approfondie notamment à
l'initiative de jean-jacques hyest
président de la commission des lois
pour ma part je souhaiterais que les
principes fondamentaux de la république
de respect de chacun de sanctions
individuelles soient totalement
respectés ils ont été écornées et je
souhaite aussi transmettre peut être un
signal de manière avec d'autres
collègues alerté sur cette législation
surabondante et parfois très limite en
termes de respect des principes
républicains
il ya aussi le problème de l'application
des lois que vous évoquez ses seins je
crois que plutôt que de légiférer il
faut aujourd'hui peut-être qu'on soit
plus tôt dans les contrôles dans la
vérification des moyens pour la mise en
oeuvre des textes qui sont désormais à
dans il s'agit par exemple pour
l'obligation scolaire retirer les
allocations familiales c'est pas une
solution face à un adolescent qui ne va
plus au collège le problème il est
ailleurs donc vérifier que les textes
leur esprit et bien mise en oeuvre que
les moyens aujourd'hui de la justice qui
est en grève aujourd'hui soient
suffisants soient à la hauteur que des
priorités soient discutées partager et
puis surtout qu'on travaille tous
ensemble la police la justice
les parlementaires et les élus au
service d'une meilleure sécurité
merci fabienne keller d'avoir répondu
aux questions de public sénat tout de
suite donc direction l'hémicycle pour la
suite du projet de loi immigration
intégration et nationalité bel après
midi à tous la séance est reprise
nous reprenons la discussion du projet
de loi adopté par l'assemblée nationale
relatif à l'immigration à l'intégration
et à la nationalité
dans la discussion des articles nous
sommes parvenus à l'amendement au numéro
450 cette tendance à attirer un article
additionnel après l'article 72 alors
nous allons examiner l'amendement 457
que va présenter monsieur young merci
madame la présidente je pense cet
amendement qui est un amendement qui va
rencontrer du succès puisqu'il propose
non pas un rapport mais deux rapports ah
oui la matière suffisante pour demander
deux rapports nous savons que le
gouvernement elle certaine amitié pour
ses rapports l'un concernerait la police
aux frontières tandis que le second se
importerait plus particulièrement à la
coopération européenne en matière de
démantèlement des filières
d'exploitation de traite humaine
plus sérieusement notre idée derrière se
demande de rapport serait de faire
avancer la réflexion sur le
fonctionnement de la police des
frontières nous savons qu'il ya des
problèmes de formation en particulier
des problèmes d'effectif et sur le
second sujet dont que j'ai mentionnés je
crois que la matière est suffisamment
explicite puisqu'il s'agit des filières
d'exploitation de la traite humaine pour
lesquels une coopération européenne est
absolument nécessaire
voilà pourquoi nous demandons de
monsieur le rapporteur pour la
commission des lois il s'agissant d'un
pardon dans une demande de deux rapports
supplémentaires avis défavorable de la
commission à l'amendement 457 l'avis du
gouvernement madame le ministre
le président messieurs les sénateurs je
comprend l'esprit votre amendement mais
c'est encore un énième rapport alors que
le code de l'entrée et du séjour des
étrangers et du droit d'asile prévoient
la remise au parlement de rapports
annuels et globale sur tous les aspects
de la politique d'immigration
ce rapport à d'importants éléments qui
permet effectivement de mesures et les
décisions qui sont prises pour la lutte
contre le travail illégal et la lutte
contre les filières d'immigration
illégale n'est pas nécessaire d'ajouter
un rapport supplémentaire donc pour ces
raisons gouvernement émet un avis
défavorable bien je mets aux voix cet
amendement 457 ceux qui sont favorables
à son adoption
l'apal compte oui garder là que l'on
puisse book ou bien vous montez merci et
pour d'autre part dont trois adoptés
lundi avec lui dans l'article 73
l'amendement 83 rectifié monsieur mais à
temps de suivre les à madame la
présidente vous envoyer un ministre mes
chers collègues il s'agit d'un
amendement de coordination en
manifestant notre opposition modalités
l'interdiction de séjour fortassin
l'avis de la commission
l'avis du gouvernement vaut râble je
mets aux voix cet amendement 83 ceux qui
sont favorables à son adoption chose
n'est pas adopté
il n'est pas adopté et je vous demande
de vous prononcer sur l'article 60
le rapport s'est prononcé
si vous voulez bien on va reprendre le
rapporteur s'est exprimé le ministre
s'est exprimé je fait voter sur 7
cet amendement 83 ceux qui sont
favorables
s'il vous il n'a pas été fait monsieur
sueur il n'a pas été fait c'est pour ça
que attendait messieurs si vous voulez
prendre la parole oui je suis prête à
vous entendre mais si vous vouliez
parler aussi vous voulez prendre la
parole moi je vous invite à prendre le
micro moi ça m'est égal
bon alors j'étais en train de vous
demander quel était ce qui était
favorable à cet amendement vous lever la
main s'il ya un doute on fera lever
debout assis debout au monde folle
et
jeux wii non ne cherchez pas des choses
qui n'existent pas j'ai pas cherché à
vous nuire j'essaye d'être le plus
neutre possible monsieur soir vous le
savez très bien
alors maintenant je vous demande à ceux
qui veulent voter contre de se prononcer
il n'est pas adoptée et sur l'article 73
si vous voulez bien vous prononcer elle
vous d'accord pour l'adoption de
l'article 73 merci 74 sans problème
74e vi trois amendements dont ils font
l'objet d'une discussion commune est
d'abord le 84 rectifier que présente
monsieur forte à sa merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
cet article interdit en demandeurs
d'asile de solliciter l'aide
juridictionnelle dans le cadre d'un
recours dirigé contre une décision de
leur froid
rejetant sa demande de réexamen lorsque
le requérant a déjà bénéficié de cette
aide devant le même office ou la cnd à
cet article institue encore une fois
comme à l'article 34 du projet de loi
une restriction du droit au recours
effectif garanti à la fois par nos
principes de valeur constitutionnelle et
l'article 13 de la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme
il est d'autant plus inacceptable que la
directive et du 1er décembre 2005
relative à des normes minimales
concernant la procédure d'octroi et de
retrait du statut de réfugié dans les
états membres ne vise pas les réexamens
mais les recours devant d'autres
juridictions
si monsieur fortassin l'amendement 229
c'est madame mathon poinat qu'il
présente mais oui merci madame la
présidente et c'est une défense commune
avec l'amendement 230 donc deux ans à
peine après la générisation de l'aide
juridictionnelle à la cnda et créer une
restriction de ce droit sans que cela
soit d'une véritable efficacité pour la
juridiction
en effet selon les auteurs de
l'amendement à l'origine de cet article
elle serait justifiée par le fait que
les demandes des jo
sonel présenté après enrôlement sera
l'origine de 20% des renvois
or la demande de dette juridictionnelle
à l'audience n'est pas la cause
principale des renvois mais le nombre
trop important d'affaires inscrites au
rôle qui a conduit d'ailleurs les
formations de jugement à renvoyer les
affaires pour audience tardive qui est
fort différent d'autres renvois sont
justifiées par l'absence de l'avocat qui
en avait pourtant dûment avertis la cour
ou par l'absence d'une partie où d'une
totalité d'un dossier par ailleurs de
façon assez récurrente les avocats
désignés par le bureau d'aidé
juridictionnelle le sont très
tardivement et sont dans l'obligation de
solliciter le report de la sphère soit
parce qu'ils n'ont pu rencontrer leurs
clients avant l'audience soit parce
qu'ils n'ont pas été en mesure de
produire avant le délai de clôture les
pièces de dossiers nécessaires c'est
donc davantage l'organisation de la cour
qui est en cause et non une prétendue
manoeuvres dilatoires du demandeur aussi
prévoir l'exclusion des demandeurs de
l'ensemble de recours est contraire au
droit positif français et non conformes
à la directive 2005 85 du conseil du 1er
décembre 2005
en effet la jurisprudence du conseil
d'état encadre et la procédure de
réexamen et a fixé des critères précis
sur la recevabilité d'une demande de
réexamen
elle reconnaît que le demandeur d'asile
qui soumet des faits nouveaux a le droit
de voir examiner sa demande et doit
bénéficier d'une admission au séjour et
des conditions matérielles d'accueil le
priver d'un conseil au titre de l'aide
juridictionnelle serait donc une
atteinte au droit à un recours effectif
et d'autre part le paragraphe 4 de cette
même directive indique clairement que si
des éléments ou des faits nouveaux
apparaissent où sont présentées par le
demandeur et qu'ils augmentent de
manière significative la probabilité que
le demandeur remplissent les conditions
requises pour prétendre au statut de
réfugié
l'examen de la demande est poursuivi
conformément aux dispositions du
chapitre 2 donc privé les demandeurs
d'asile dont la demande est recevable
dans réexamen de l'aide juridictionnelle
et donc injustifiable c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous demandons dans le
premier amendement bien évidemment la
suppression et pour le second
l'extension de l'aide juridique à tous
les demandeurs d'asile merci mme asha
collègues de 458,6 madame bonne
comédienne teri qui le défend oui pour
aller dans le même sens que les
collègues je souhaite dire que depuis le
1er décembre 2008 cette aide
juridictionnelle peut être octroyée à
tous les requérants qui remplissent les
conditions exigées comme le plafond de
ressources
quelle que soit la régularité de leur
entrée sur le territoire national la
suppression de l'exigence d'entrée
régulière sur le territoire français
pour demander l'aide juridictionnelle
date de la dernière loi sur
l'immigration en 2006 et déjà vous nous
demandez de légiférer en sens inverse
en effet l'article 74 bis avant que la
commission des lois du sénat et apporte
quelques sages insuffisante message
modifications interdisait qu'un migrants
puissent bénéficier de l'aide
juridictionnelle dans le cadre d'un
recours contre la décision de l'ofpra
rejetant la demande de réexamen de sa
demande d'asile
on comprend bien que ceux qui
s'introduisait cette mesure laissé
entendre que toute nouvelle demande de
protection seraient par nature abusive
pourtant après le rejet définitif d'une
demande d'une première demande d'asile
seule la présentation d'éléments
nouveaux permet le réexamen d'une
demande donc cette mesure est une
atteinte grave au droit d'asile
les modifications apportées par la
commission des lois ne sont pas de
nature à grandir ni à 40 à garantir le
fait que les demandeurs d'asile puissent
bénéficier d'un recours effectif devant
la juridiction en étant défendu en effet
avec les modifications apportées par la
commission des lois
cette aide juridictionnelle
ne pourrait pas être demandé devant la
cnda dans le cas d'une demande de
réexamen
dès lors que le requérant à l'occasion
d'une précédente demande a déjà été
entendu par l'ofpra ainsi que la part la
cour assisté d'un avocat désigné au
titre même de cette aide
juridictionnelle
selon le rapporteur le fait de refuser à
certains demandeurs d'asile la
possibilité de demander l'aide
juridictionnelle serait justifiée par
l'article 15 de la directive 2005
relative à des normes minimales
concernant la procédure d'octroi et de
retrait du statut des réfugiés dans les
états membres
il semble que l'on puisse faire dire
tout et son contraire au droit
communautaire
je ne veux pas entrer dans une querelle
d'interprétation de la directive mais je
laisse à la cour de justice de l'union
européenne qui vous ne manquerez pas de
l'avoir remarqué rang depuis quelques
années des avis qui vont dans tous dans
le sens d'une amélioration du niveau de
protection des migrants et des
demandeurs d'asile en particulier nantis
ce que la sensibilité des intérêts
nationaux par est elle plus
circonstancielle je n'entrerai donc pas
dans une querelle d'interprétation sur
cet article 15 de la directive
européenne mais je souligne que cette
directive comme l'indiquent son nom est
relative à des normes minimales
concernant la procédure d'octroi et de
retrait du statut de réfugié dans les
états membres et elle le fixe donc des
règles minimales
selon ce principe d'harmonisation
minimale largement utilisée dans le cas
de la route construction européenne les
états sont libres d'adopter ou de
conserver des normes plus protectrice
c'est pourquoi nous vous proposons de
conserver dans notre droit national la
possibilité pour tout demandeur d'asile
de pouvoir demander cette aide
juridictionnelle comme cela déjà
existent d'autant plus que la loi des
finances pour 2011 est déjà venus rogner
sur ce droit en limitant à un mois le
délai pour demander l'aide
juridictionnelle
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que je
vous propose de supprimer cet article
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
la commission oui même le président donc
sur l'amendement 84 rectifier le 229 et
de 458 sur le même objet la commission
des lois a émis un avis défavorable
je voudrais rappeler que les
dispositions de l'article 74 ben ça a
été introduit par le projet de loi à
temps par nos collègues députés vise à
encadrer et à rationaliser l'octroi de
l'aide judiciaire devant la cour
nationale du droit d'asile
nos collègues ont souhaité exclure du
bénéfice de l'aide judiciaire les
requérants sollicitant leur examen de
leur demande d'asile car ils ont
considéré que la plupart de ces demandes
avaient un caractère dilatoire
la commission des lois du sénat a
atténué ses dispositions en réservant
l'hypothèse d'un demandeur d'asile qui
n'auraient pas été entendu en première
demande par un officier de protection ou
par la cour nationale du droit d'asile
il me semble qu'à ci définit ces
conditions permettent de définir un
équilibre entre la nécessaire
rationalisation à l'accès à l'est du 10
hier à l'aide juridictionnelle devant la
cour et les garanties essentielles
apporter aux demandeurs d'asile
au demeurant ces dispositions sont
conformes aux dispositions de l'article
15 de la directive du 1er décembre 2005
avis donc défavorable merci madame le
ministre l'avis du gouvernement est la
main présidente par rapport à ces trois
amendements de suppression je crois
qu'il est important de rappeler que le
projet de loi prévoit de supprimer
l'aide juridictionnelle
non pas pour l'examen de la demande
d'asile
mais pour les recours présentés sur les
décisions de l'ofpra rejetant le
réexamen d'une demande d'asile est
d'ailleurs votre commission des lois
amendées cette disposition en prévoyant
deux conditions le réglerait qui rend
droit à voir a été entendu par le fera
le requérant doit avoir comparu la
première fois devant la cour nationale
du droit d'asile assisté d'un avocat
désigné au titre de l'aide
juridictionnelle
le gouvernement est votre commission des
lois partage donc l'objectif de
restreint glacée à l'aide
juridictionnelle dans les pouilles
procédure de réexamen est d'ailleurs
dans le respect du droit communautaire
c'est-à-dire la directive du 1er
décembre 2005 dite directive procédure
cette réforme poursuit donc un double
objectif améliorer le fonctionnement de
la cour et réduire ses délais de
traitement que tous s'accordent à
considérer qu'ils sont excessifs
puisqu'ils sont le prêt de 15 mois
prévenir les recours abusifs c'est la
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
n'est pas favorable à aucun de ces
amendements de suppression
merci s'il n'y a pas de demande
d'explications de vote je vais mettre
aux voix
et trois amendements identiques de
suppression ceux qui sont favorables à
ces amendements vont bien l'exprimer en
levant la main ceux qui sont contre ils
ne sont pas adoptées lors le 230 vous
l'avez déjà défendu madame mathon poinat
l'avis de la commission sur le 230
défavorable madame la présidence sur le
230 les durées dictionnaire n'est
possible que devant la cour nationale du
droit d'asile
puisque l'ofpra est un établissement
dont toute façon il est possible que
devant une juridiction et le froid est
un établissement public administratif
avis défavorable l'avis du gouvernement
madame le ministre vo rabelais je mets
aux voix cet amendement 230 ceux qui
sont favorables à son adoption
hebron la main
contre il n'est pas adopté je mets aux
voix l'article 74 luis ceux qui sont
favorables à l'adoption de l'article 74
bis
ceux qui sont contre
il est adopté après l'article 74 10 lun
articles additionnels tels articles
additionnels deux amendements identiques
le 243 que défend madame assassi ou
madame à temps plein il a défendu le 472
madame caries merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre monsieur rapporteur
mes chers collègues le présenta moment
vise à supprimer la procédure dite
prioritaire
l'examen des demandes d'asile cette
procédure accélérée est utilisé pour les
demandeurs d'asile provenant de pays
d'origine sûrs pour les personnes
considérées comme représentant une
menace pour l'ordre public et pour
celles dont la demande est jugée
frauduleuse abusives ou seulement
destiné à empêcher la mise en oeuvre
d'une mesure d'éloignement
elle est également utilisée lorsque des
demandeurs d'asile déboutés demande à
l'offre à de réexaminer leur demande sur
la base d'informations nouvelles
par ailleurs les demandeurs d'asile
placés en rétention est en instance
d'éloignement sont aussi soumis à la
procédure prioritaire en 2009 plus de 22
% des demandes d'asile ont été examinée
selon la procédure dite prioritaire la
limitation des droits découlant de cette
procédure et dénoncé par toutes les
associations de défense des droits de
l'homme qui affirme que ce système est
injuste et dangereux
l'ancien commissaire aux droits de
l'homme du conseil de l'europe
monsieur alvaro gil robles dans son
rapport sur le respect effectif des
droits de l'homme en france relevé à
propos de la procédure dite prioritaire
je le cite qu'elle est loin d'offrir les
mêmes garanties que la demande d'asile
de droit commun et qu'en définitive elle
nous laisse qu'une chance infime ou
demandeur
l'existence de cette procédure prouve
que la france n'est pas contrairement à
ce que le gouvernement laisse croire le
pays le plus généreux en matière d'asile
pour que la france puisse réellement
mérité ce statut exemplaires il apparaît
nécessaire et urgent de supprimer la
procédure dite prioritaire pour toutes
ces raisons je vise je vous invite à
adopter le présente un moment de
suppression merci beaucoup
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur m le président sur le 243
rectifié sur 472 rectifier la commission
des lois a émis un avis défavorable
pardon puisque cet amendement ces
amendements visent à supprimer le
dispositif de procédure prioritaire qui
permet effectivement à l'ofpra de
traiter un certain nombre de dossiers
très spécifique de façon assez rapide je
rappelle que les délais d'attentes pour
un demandeur d'asile procédure of propre
sur cdac entre 19 et 20 mois et qu'il
faut conserver quand même les des
produits procédure d'examen qui soit
tout de même dans des cas particuliers
comme ceux ci assez rapide
je rappelle par ailleurs que ce système
la procédure prioritaire été validée par
le conseil constitutionnel dans sa
décision du 13 août 93 et qui est
surtout conforme à nos engagements
communautaires
merci madame le ministre l'avis
défavorable
s'il n'y a pas de demande d'explications
de vote je mets aux voix ces deux
amendements identiques ceux qui sont
favorables son adoption à leur adoption
danse ceux qui sont contre ils ne sont
pas adoptées ou bien de venir à
l'article 75
trois amendements identiques de
suppression le l'amendement numéro 85
rectifié monsieur fortassin madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues à l'ajout d'un nouveau cas où
vendre l'examen de la demande d'asile de
procédure prioritaire
cet article introduit une nouvelle
restriction pour l'admission séjour
provisoire du demandeur d'asile selon le
droit actuel ils reviennent à
l'administration de démontrer que la
dissimulation constitue une fraude
délibérée or c'est un article inverse en
quelque sorte la charge de la preuve
puisqu'il fait par exemple la fraude
pour dissimulation d'informations
concernant l'identité la norme
à charge pour le demandeur d'asile
d'apporter la justification que cette
dissimulation rapport à des motivations
les victimes
on venait à - songer aux personnes
persécutées dans leur pays qui pour des
raisons de sécurité sont obligés
dissimuler leur véritable identité
or les délais particulier de procédures
ainsi que la complexité de cette
dernière va alourdir les obligations du
demandeur d'asile au risque d'affaiblir
sa demande
j'ajouterai que la procédure prioritaire
est elle même une réelle restriction des
droits des demandeurs d'asile qui
conviendra devraient emménager dans un
sens plus respectueux du principe du
contradictoire
merci mais le 233 oui madame cherche
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
cette disposition résulte d'une décision
du conseil d'état qui a qualifié de
frauduleuses et la demande d'une
personne dont les empreintes
dactyloscopiques n'ont pu être relevées
dans le cadre du règlement eurodac
application du règlement dublin 2
surtout cette réforme intervient dans un
contexte où la gestion expéditif des
demandes d'asile ne cessent d'augmenter
désormais plus de la moitié des demandes
examiné en procédure prioritaire sont
des premières demandes d'asile dans ce
contexte l'absence de contrôle réel
efficace du recours à la procédure
prioritaire et compte tenu de l'intérêt
qu'elles représentent pour le
gouvernement de point de vue budgétaire
les craintes quant aux dérives de cette
disposition sont bien réels le placement
en procédure prioritaire prive le
demandeur d'une instruction effective de
sa requête sans possibilité de recours
suspensif devant la cour nationale du
droit d'asile
tout en le contraignant lorsqu'il n'est
pas mise en rétention administrative à
vivre dans des conditions de grande
précarité avec des droits sociaux
économiques fortement minoré la nouvelle
précision comporte d'une part un élément
matériel fournir de fausses informations
dissimulé des informations comme
l'identité la nationalité modalités
d'entrée est un élément intentionnel
volonté d'induire en erreur les
autorités dans cette nouvelle hypothèse
de refus d'admission séjour le préfet
devra donc démontrer qu'il a en sa
possession des indications et
informations permettant d'établir que
les déclarations de l'intéressé sont
erronés ou avait été dissimulée que la
personne n'avait réellement l'intention
d'induire en erreur l'administration
avec la mise en oeuvre de ce nouveau
mécanisme le demandeur sera exposé dès
ses premières démarches un service
public préfectoral guidé par une logique
de contrôle alors qu'il en général fui
des persécutions ou a pu subir des actes
de tortures ou des traitements cruels
inhumains ou dégradants d'agents
étatique sans être protégé en raison de
la défaillance des autorités du pays
d'où il vient
or dans une situation d'extrême
vulnérabilité psychologiquement
fragilise
et le demandeur a souvent perdu toute
confiance dans ce qui à ses yeux
ressemblent à l'autorité il peut dans un
premier temps ne pas vouloir ou ne pas
pouvoir révéler des informations au
stade de son admission au séjour alors
que ses craintes de persécutions en cas
de retour sont fondés par ailleurs du
fait d'un usage non réglementées en
pratique mais régulièrement dénoncé par
les associations de la procédure
prioritaire par les services
préfectoraux
il est à craindre que l'invocation de
cette nouvelle disposition ne devienne
trop systématique comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui déjà pour d'autres motifs
légaux de refus d'admission provisoire
aux six jours ainsi par exemple une
personne pourrait elle être placée en
procédure prioritaire sur ce fondement
lorsqu'elle se déclarera sur son
identité réelle au service d'une
préfecture mais que le fichage eurodac
révélera une identité différente est
donc fausse fournies précédemment dans
un autre état membre il est à craindre
que dans le doute les services
préfectoraux préfère appliquer ce motif
de reçu de refus d'admission séjour et
arguent de l'impossibilité de déterminer
l'identité réelle de la personne je
globalise avec l'amendement 236 merci
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
demandons non seulement la suppression
de cet article mais aussi la suppression
de la présomption de recours abusifs
prévu par l'ani le quatrième man de
l'article l7 141 4 et donc j'ai soutenu
en même temps l'amendement 236 le vous
remercie tivo cole la caisse qui
ignorerait présente l'amendement 461
monsieur monsieur soir merci madame la
présidente de me donner la parole madame
la ministre mes chers collègues
vous savez que la france est très
profondément attaché au droit d'asile au
respect du droit d'asile
ça fait partie de l'identité de notre
pays que d'offrir son accueil aux
personnes qui sont persécutés
marty
is et dans quelques pays que cela soit
or tout le monde a compris et je pense
que monsieur mézard comme adam cherche
ont été extrêmement précis
madame la présidente madame la ministre
cet article 75 il vise indirectement à
élargir l'application de la procédure
prioritaire
or cette procédure accélérée prive les
candidats à l'asile de tout titre
provisoire de séjour et autorise
l'administration à les expulser avant
même l'examen par la cour nationale du
droit d'asile de la décision de rejet de
la demande d'asile
autrement dit c'est une procédure
particulière
je sais que monsieur le rapporteur qui
viennent décision du conseil
constitutionnel
n'empêche qu'il s'agit d'une procédure
expéditive que ces procédures se traduit
par l'absence de recours suspensif pour
les personnes qui invoque les risques de
persécution en cas de renvoi dans leur
pays
pour nous ce n'est pas satisfaisant
et c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs madame la
présidente et madame la ministre vous
n'ignorez pas que le conseil
constitutionnel qui a été évoqué par
monsieur le rapporteur devra
prochainement dire si l'absence de
recours suspensif devant la cnd a est
conforme à l'article 16 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen qui dispose vous le savez que
toute société dans laquelle la garantie
des droits n'est pas assurée ni la
séparation des pouvoirs déterminée n'a
point de constitution
hier la cour de cassation en effet
décidé de transmettre au conseil
constitutionnel une question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité notre rapporteur a
proposé d'exclure du dispositif prévu à
l'article 75 les personnes qui
dissimulent les éléments sur leur
identité ou les modalités de leur entrée
en france pour des motifs légitimes mais
vous savez bien
kylie à des étrangers qui font l'objet
de menaces de la part de passeurs qui ne
peuvent pas dire la vérité
en raison de ces menaces c'est pourquoi
nous nous demandons simplement qu'on
applique les règles générales du droit
on a le droit à un recours suspensif et
c'est pourquoi nous pensons qu'il serait
sage de supprimer cet article
parce que nous pensons que les
procédures expéditives et les procédures
la procédure donc dites prioritaires ne
présente pas les garanties nécessaires
par rapport à quelque chose qui est
aussi important que le droit d'asile
monsieur le rapporteur madame le
président le ministre sur les
amendements 85 rectifié 233 et 461 la
commission des lois est bien un avis
défavorable pour les motifs suivants
strictes sont sous l'article 75 du
projet loi n'étant pas le champ des
hypothèses justifiant l'examen d'une
demande d'asile selon la procédure dite
prioritaire mais précise la notion de
demandes d'asile reposant sur une fraude
délibérée figurant déjà dans les
dispositions de l'article l7 141-1 du
code des étrangers
son but est de prévenir les pratiques de
certains demandeurs d'asile tendant à
altérer leur empreinte digitale afin
d'empêcher leur identification par le
dispositif eurodac ou à terre sciemment
certains éléments de leur parcours tels
que des séjours antérieures dans
d'autres états membres de l'union
européenne
de telles pratiques font déjà l'objet de
sanctions par le juge administratif
l'article 75 du projet permettra
d'unifier la pratique des préfectures en
la matière j'ajoute que la commission
des lois a toutefois souhaité réserver
l'hypothèse ou l'altération des
empreintes ou le silence sur certains
éléments parcours relèverait d'un motif
légitime
par exemple lorsque la sécurité du
demandeur d'asile est menacée sur ce
point il semble que le projet est
parvenu un bon équilibre ce qui justifie
donc l'avis défavorable sur ces trois
amendements merci madame le ministre
l'avis du gouvernement
madame la présidente le gouvernement est
défavorable à cet amendement qui
supprime l'article 75 du projet de loi
l'article 75 est nécessaire sur la base
effectivement de l'argumentaire que
vient de développer le rapporteur je
voudrais simplement préciser c'est que
l'application de cette disposition à les
encadrer l'utilisation de la procédure
prioritaire n'est pas automatique et
résulte d'un examen individuel cette
procédure d'ailleurs ne sera utilisée
que si l'étranger dissimule délibérément
des informations dans le but de tromper
les autorités françaises puis vous avez
beaucoup parlé j'ai entendu de procédure
expéditive voudrais simplement vous
rappeler que le constat est le suivant
c'est que actuellement c'est il ya 145
jours de traitement d'une demande
d'asile devant l'offre à 40,445 jours
devant la cndh et donc le projet de loi
prévoit de permettre effectivement de
consacrer plus de temps aux demandes qui
ne sont pas abusives et globalement de
réduire les délais sa disposition ne
prive nullement ni les personnes ni du
droit à demander l'asile ni du droit
obtenir une protection mais se limite à
ménager les modalités procédurales
l'examen de leur demande d'asile en
soumettant à la procédure prioritaire
merci madame le ministre s'il n'y a pas
de demande d'explications de vote
monsieur sueur oui madame la présidente
madame la ministre j'ai été très surpris
de la déclaration que vient de faire
madame la ministre madame la ministre
vous nous dites voilà il ya deux
procédures une procédure rapide une
procédure plus longue et nous pensons
qu'il est mieux de consacrer plus de
temps aux procédures qui ne sont pas
abusives aux demandes qui ne sont pas
abusives
mais en ce jour où beaucoup de
magistrats sont inquiets madame la
ministre
il serait peut être sage de ne pas
ajouter we made monsieur le président de
la commission des lois vous êtes le
gardien des lois il serait extrêmement
le sage de ne pas ajouter des
déclarations qui pose problème à
d'autres qui ont posé problème car si
vous dites madame mais écoutez mes chers
collègues
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord vous direz
pourquoi si madame la ministre
mais si madame la ministre dit mais
monsieur mon cher collègue
si madame la ministre dit il faut il
faut accorder plus de temps aux demandes
qui ne sont pas abusives qu'aux demandes
abusives
d'accord ça veut dire qu'au départ elle
sait qu'il ya des demandes abusives
or quelle est justement l'objet mais non
mais quel est l'objet de la procédure
c'est de savoir justement s'il a des
demandes et abusive ou pas abusive
c'est d'une totale évidence donc madame
madame la ministre
si vous dites à priori qu'il y a des
demandes d'asile qui sont présentés qui
sont abusives pour lesquels il faut donc
aller vite et que donc ne sont pas
abusives
ça veut dire que vous avez jugé avant
même que la procédure ne commence donc
cette déclaration est particulièrement
maladroite et j'espère que vous aurez à
coeur madame la ministre de la rectifier
mais bien sûr que oui enfin écouté mon
cher collègue si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord expliquez moi pourquoi je
serais très heureux donc de comprendre
mais sardi od poursuivait s'il vous
plaît si on dit au départ madame la
présidente qui lie à des demandes qui
sont abusives
ça veut dire qu'on les a jugés avant de
les examiner et d'eau mais nommée même
apprécié mais mon cher collègue l'objet
de la procédure est de savoir si la
demande est pertinente recevables ou si
elle est abusive
c'est l'objet de la procédure si on nous
dit au départ il faut une procédure
accélérée pour les demandes abusives
ça veut dire qu'on a déclaré avant de
les regarder quelles sont abusives ne
sais pas comment expliquer les choses
mais je crois que je suis claire dont il
me semble qu'un membre du goût du
gouvernement ne peut pas nous déclaré
qu'a priori il y à des demandes qui
avant tout tout commencement d'examen
seraient considérées comme abusives
voilà si le après cette explication de
vote je vais faire voter sur tous les
trois amendements identiques de
suppression quels sont ceux qui sont
favorables à leur adoption
contre ils ne sont pas adoptées 11
amendement faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement 480,2 qu'il présente qui
monsieur alors monsieur 482 ce monsieur
soir qu'il présente alors à l'isi merci
madame la présidente
dans madame la ministre j'aurais aimé
être honorée d'une réponse mais je vois
qu'il y en a pas
le conseil constitutionnel et le conseil
d'état ont consacré le principe de
l'admission au séjour des demandeurs
d'asile jusqu'à la décision de la cour
nationale du droit d'asile
mais quatre exceptions à ce principe
sont prévues par l'article l
741 4 du ceseda il s'agit premièrement
des personnes dont la demande d'asile
relève de la compétence d'un autre état
membre de l'union européenne en
application du règlement dublin ii
deuxièmement des personnes originaires
d'un pays considérés comme sûrs
troisièmement des personnes qui
représentent une menace grave pour la
société quatrièmement des personnes dont
la demande reposerait sur une fraude
délibérée
cela donc fait au total beaucoup de
monde or les personnes relevant de ces
quatre exceptions voient leur demande
d'asile examiné en procédure dite
prioritaire c'est à dire qu'elles ne
bénéficient pas d'un droit au séjour et
que l'offre aastra tu statut de manière
accélérée sur leur cas et surtout que le
recours devant la cnda n'a pas
aujourd'hui d'effet suspensif l'étranger
peut donc être reconduit à la frontière
dès que la décision de rejet de l'offre
à lui a été notifié or je tiens à
souligner que le fait que la procédure
prioritaire concerne pour l'année 2010
un quart des demandes par cet amendement
nous vous proposons de garantir à tous
les demandeurs d'asile un titre de
séjour le droit à un recours effectif et
le bénéfice de conditions d'accueil
à cette fin nous réclamons donc la
suppression des quatre exceptions de
refus de séjour décrite à l'article
741 4 car la procédure prioritaire et
pour nous inéquitable injuste et elle ne
garantit pas suffisamment le respect du
droit d'asile
si fondamental pour la république
française sinon chaque collègue madame
cherche présente le 234 merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues nous estimons à l'instar de
nombreuses instances internationales et
européennes que la procédure dite
prioritaire ne présente pas les
garanties inhérentes à la particularité
de la situation des demandeurs d'asile
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
est actuellement saisie de cette requête
dirigée contre la france chacune se
fondant sur l'absence de recours
systématiquement suspensif devant la
semaine des as en violation des articles
3 et 13 de la convention lors de
l'examen en mai 2010 du rapport
périodique de la france
le comité contre la torture a déclaré
qu'il n'était pas convaincu que la
procédure prioritaire offre des
garanties suffisantes contre un
éloignement emportant comportant un
risque de torture et recommandait que la
france mette en place un recours
suspensif pour ses demandes
le comité des droits de l'homme a
considéré en 2008 que la france devrait
veiller à ce que la décision de renvoyer
un étranger y compris un demandeur
d'asile soit prise à l'issue d'une
procédure équitable qui permet d'exclure
effectivement le risque réel de
violations graves des droits de l'homme
dont l'intéressé pourrait être victime à
son retour tout en veillant à ce qu'ils
puissent exercer un droit de recours
avec effet suspensif
continuant le commissaire aux droits de
l'homme du conseil de l'europe en 2006 a
considéré que cette procédure était je
cite loin d'offrir les mêmes garanties
que la demande que la demande d'asile de
droit commun et qu'elle ne laissait
qu'une chance infime aux demandeurs
les conclusions de l'arrêt si on y
ajoute les condamnations de l' agence
des nations unies pour les réfugiés qui
a aussi affirmé je cite que la procédure
prioritaire ne présente pas toutes les
garanties requises pour assurer un
respect effectif du principe de non
refoulement
enfin la cour de cassation a déposé une
question préalable de constitutionnalité
sur l'absence de recours suspensif en
procédure prioritaire sur laquelle les
sages ne se sont pas encore prononcés au
regard de la gravité des condamnations
de cette procédure dont les préfectures
nous le disions font un usage abusif et
systématiques afin de tenir les
objectifs chiffrés de reconduites à la
frontière du gouvernement n'a selon nous
pas lieu d'être
c'est donc la raison pour laquelle nous
vous demandons la suppression de
l'article l pardon 741 cadre du ceseda
je vous remercie petit qui défend le 459
rectifier oui madame la présidente
madame la ministre mon intervention
vient en complément de celle de notre
collègue jean pierre sueur
depuis 1993 les quatre exceptions au
principe du droit au séjour pour les
demandeurs d'asile prévue par l'article
l 714,4 du ceseda n'ont cessé de prendre
de l'ampleur en 2010 environ un quart
des demandes d'asile ont été examinés
selon les modalités prévues par la
procédure prioritaire
or cette prise cette procédure dite
prioritaire qui devrait plutôt
d'ailleurs s'appeler procédure accélérée
et profondément injuste et véritablement
inéquitable le demandeur d'asile placée
en procédure prioritaire ne bénéficient
en effet pas d'un droit au séjour mais
surtout et j'insiste sur ce point il
peut être reconduit à la frontière
dès que la décision de rejet de sa
demande par l'ofpra le été notifié car
le recours devant la cnda n'a pas
d'effet suspensif
de plus ce demandeur d'asile n'a pas
accès aux centres d'accueil pour
demandeurs d'asile
ces droits socio-économiques sont
minorer ou non donc à ce qu'un minimum
de personnes soient concernées par cette
procédure prioritaire afin de garantir
au mieux le respect du droit d'asile
c'est pourquoi nous proposons donc
qu'elle soit circonscrite aux personnes
relevant du règlement dublin 2 et c'est
pourquoi cet amendement vise à réserver
les décisions du refus d'admission au
séjour provisoire aux situations dans
lesquelles la france n'est pas
responsable de l'examen d'une demande
d'asile qui lui est présenté parce que
relevant de la responsabilité de la note
est à membres de l'union européenne
merci chaque collègue l'amendement 235
rectifié madame cherche la présidente
madame la ministre jacques collègues
donc pour cet amendement la rédaction de
cet amendement reprend les dispositions
du règlement
c'est au numéro 343 2003 établissant les
critères et les mécanismes de
détermination de l'état membre
responsable d'une demande d'asile
présentée dans l'un des états membres
par un ressortissant d'un pays tiers ces
dispositions ne font donc pas obstacle
au droit souverain de l'état d'accorder
l'asile à toute personne qui se
trouverait dans ce cas je vous invite à
voter donc cet amendement merci le 4e 26
86 rectifier ces îles monsieur mézard
les cours
merci madame le président quand même
madame le ministre mes chers collègues
il s'agit par cet amendement d'abroger
le refus de séjour lequel est pour nous
constitutifs d'une exception au principe
de l'admission au séjour des demandeurs
d'asile jusqu'à la décision de la cour
nationale du droit d'asile comme l'ont
consacré à la fois le conseil
constitutionnel et le conseil d'état des
exceptions
aujourd'hui au nombre de quatre furent
introduites depuis 1993 dans notre droit
elles aboutissent à ce qu'un tiers des
demandeurs sont aujourd'hui placés sous
le régime de la procédure dite dublin ou
de la procédure prioritaire
or le droit à un recours effectif que
nous n'avons cessé nombreux ici dans
cette enceinte de défendre tout au long
de ces débats nécessite de mettre fin à
ce traitement inéquitable en abrogeant
le refus de séjour
de plus ce dispositif donne lieu une
application extrêmement hétérogène sur
l'ensemble du territoire ce qui renforce
le caractère tout à fait inédit
inégalitaire de la procédure
c'est pourquoi nous demandons
l'abrogation de l'article l7 141,4 du
ces et dames merci le 236 il est défendu
le 460 qui le présente monsieur k merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
l'article l7 141,4 du ceseda énonce les
conditions dans lesquelles l'admission
en france d'un étranger demandant à
bénéficier de l'asile peut être refusé
il s'agit donc de refuser l'accès au
territoire avant même que l'étranger
n'est déposé sa demande
le quatrième point de cet article
prévoit que l'admission en france
demeure d'asile peut être refusée dans
deux dans trois circonstances quand sa
demande repose sur une fraude délibérée
ce qui est normal quand qu'il constitue
un recours abusif aux procédures d'asile
ou n'est présentée qu'en vue de faire
échec à une mesure d'éloignement
prononcer ou imminente
nous proposons de supprimer ce 4e point
de l'article l 741 cadre du ceseda en
effet lors de son admission en france
pour déposer une demande d'asile
l'étranger est exposée dès sa première
démarche aux services préfectoraux
guidés par une logique de contrôle et si
l'on prend un peu de recul
cette personne a pu fuir des
persécutions ou subir des actes de
torture des traitements cruels inhumains
ou dégradants par des agents étatiques
dans son pays d'origine
or dans une situation d'extrême
vulnérabilité à la fois
psychologiquement fragiliser le
demandeur a souvent perdu toute
confiance dans ce qui à ses yeux se
rapporte à l'autorité il peut dans un
premier temps ne pas vouloir ne pas
pouvoir révéler des informations au
stade de son admission au séjour alors
que ses craintes de persécutions en cas
de retour sont fondées du fait de cet
amendement les motifs de fraude
délibérée ou de recours abusifs ou de
demandes d'asile présentées qu'en vue de
faire échec à une mesure d'éloignement
ne seront plus un vocable par le préfet
pour refuser l'admission en france d'un
étranger au titre de l'asile
je remercie merci bien alors maintenant
c'est l'amendement numéro 16
qu'est-ce qui nous le présente ses amis
ne vous veniez thierry vous avez la
parole madame la sénatrice
merci monsieur le président si on voit
là je m'excuse madame associe j'avoue
que j'ai pas fait attention mais je la
découvre avec vous allez donc je peux en
fait cet amendement est un amendement ou
pourrait presque dire de repli puisque à
défaut de la suppression de l'article 75
qui doit aux minima être rédigée de
telle façon qu'il permet la
transposition de l'article l7 141,4 du
ceseda
les critères de l'annexé 2 de la
directive européenne 2005 pour fixer la
liste des pays d'origine sur cette
question de listes de pays d'origine sûr
vous savez qu'elle pose beaucoup de
problèmes qu'elle n'existe pas au niveau
européen et que les critères sont tous
différents de pays à pays
cette circulaire devait transposer avant
le 1er décembre 2007 donc on a déjà plus
de trois ans de retard et la définition
qui est donnée actuellement par la loi
ne prend en compte que certains éléments
par contre elle ne prend pas en compte
des éléments comme l'existence d'un
conflit armé d'une guerre civile
et là ça pose problème conformément à la
jurisprudence du conseil d'état il
s'agit donc de circonscrire
l'application de la notion de recours
frauduleux ou abusif aux seuls demande
manifestement dilatoire si l'intéressé
havok les éléments permettant de le
rattacher à une demande d'asile
il doit être admis au séjour dans la
temps de l'examen de sa nouvelle demande
d'asile
merci merci bien et eliane assassi et
bien à exactement même un moment oui
mais ce président donc c'était puisque
c'est le même c'est donc je reprécise
que c'est un amendement de repli
donc avec lequel nous voulons préciser
la notion de pays sûrs
donc il nous semble effectivement
impératif de modifier les termes de
l'article l7 141 péricat du ceseda et
donc d'introduire dans la loi les
critères de l' annexe 2 de la directive
2005 85 c e pour fixer la liste des pays
d'origine sûrs qu'ils devraient qui
devait être transposée avant le 1er
décembre 2007
donc nous l'avons dit précédemment la
définition qui est donnée par la loi ne
prend pas en compte certains éléments
comme l'exemple a été donnée mais
l'existence d'un conflit armé
de plus effectivement il ya la
jurisprudence du conseil
des tactiques il circonscrit
l'application de la notion de recours
frauduleux ou abusif à au sol demande
manifestement dilatoire donc si
l'intéressé invoque les éléments
permettant de le rattacher à une demande
d'asile
il doit être admis au séjour c'est donc
le sens de cet amendement merci bien
nous avons deux amendements identiques
donc je vais demander qu'est-ce qui nous
présente le 237 rectifier c'est toujours
eliane assassi oui monsieur le président
est bien évidemment cet amendement n'est
pas en contradiction avec le précédent
il lui simplement à démontrer pourquoi
la liste des et pourquoi il sur le fond
la liste des pays d'origine
devraient être supprimés en effet la
présence d'un état sur la liste des pays
d'origine sûrs exclu c'est ressortissant
d'un certain nombre de droits et surtout
elle autorise le renvoi dans leur pays
avant même que la cnd a et statuer sur
leur requête
la décision du conseil d'état du 23
juillet 2010 qui a conduit au retrait de
cette liste de l'arménie de madagascar
de la turquie et pour les ressortissants
de sexe féminin du mali montre que tout
montre toute la difficulté
d'établissement d'une telle liste par
ailleurs aucun accord communautaire n'a
d'ailleurs été possible sur les pays
devant être retenu cette liste empêche
un grand nombre de leurs ressortissants
d'être reconnus réfugiés ou
bénéficiaires de la protection
subsidiaire
car aujourd'hui beaucoup de leurs
demandes sont rejetées en première
instance par l'ofpra et accepter
seulement au niveau du recours par la
cndr il estime ainsi que ce principe est
contraire au principe de non
discrimination en raison du pays
d'origine et qui permet d'en tirer de
tirer d'une situation générale prévalant
dans un état des conséquences qui
s'imposent pour des situations
éminemment individuelle et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous demandons la
suppression de cette liste très bien le
477 rectifié biz c'est ronan kerdraon
qui nous le présente tout à fait
monsieur le président madame la ministre
deux pêcheurs collègues depuis la loi du
10 décembre 2003 le préfet peut refuser
d'admettre au séjour des étrangers
originaires d'un pays estimés sur en
vertu de l'alinéa 2 de l'article l7 141
4 du code de l'entrée et du séjour des
étrangers et du droit d'asile
un pays considéré comme sûr et je cite
s'il veille au respect des principes de
liberté de la démocratie et de l'état de
droit ainsi que des droits de l'homme et
des libertés fondamentales
or la liste des pays d'origine sûrs
établi à partir des critères précités et
profondément insatisfaisant de s'était
rappelée par ma collègue précédemment
c'est pourquoi depuis son arrêt du 13
février 2008 le conseil d'état acceptent
de contrôler la légalité interne
de cette liste dans un récent arrêt en
date du 23 juillet 2010 ce conseil
d'état a franchi une étape
supplémentaire en invalidant un certain
nombre de pays le mali madagascar
l'arménie l'arctique la turquie la
fréquence des pratiques d'excision la
persécution des opposants au régime ou
encore l'instabilité politique et
sociale interne de ces états ont été
autant de raisons invoquées par la plus
haute juridiction administrative
encore aujourd'hui il est possible de
s'interroger sur la cohérence et le bien
fondé de cette liste en effet comment
des pays pratiquant la peine de mort
comme le bénin la tanzanie la mongolie
le ghana peuvent-ils être considérés
comme sûrs alors même qu'il menace la
vie de leurs ressortissants nous sentons
bien que cette liste n'a aucune
légitimité en soi d'ailleurs à l'échelle
communautaire
aucun accord sur l'élaboration d'une
telle liste n'ait été trouvé cette liste
certes bien plus les intérêts
diplomatiques de la france qu'elle ne
protège les demandeurs d'asile en effet
la liste des pays d'origine sûrs permet
le placement en procédure prioritaire
d'un demandeur d'asile
or cette procédure est une entrave aux
droits des demandeurs d'asile dans cette
hypothèse les demandeurs ne bénéficie
pas d'un droit au séjour et s'ils
peuvent sévir l'office français de
protection des réfugiés et des à prat et
des apatrides
le recours devant la cour nationale du
droit d'asile n'est pas suspensif
autrement dit dès que l'offre a notifié
sa décision de rejet l'étranger peut
être expulsé par conséquent nous
personne nous percevons parfaitement la
logique que sous-tend la liste des pays
d'origine sûrs elle permet d'accélérer
des reconduites à la frontière en
déclenchant la procédure dite
prioritaire
si le zèle du gouvernement en la matière
n'est plus à démontrer et doit cependant
être combattu avec acharnement
quand les droits fondamentaux des
demandeurs d'asile ne sont pas
respectées et qu'il n'existe pas de
garantie quant aux risques de
persécution et d'exactions à leur
encontre
le gouvernement fait preuve je dois le
dire d'une hypocrisie honteuse en
protégeant en prétendant protéger la vie
et les droits des demandeurs d'asile
tout en déclenchant la procédure dite
prioritaire
ainsi l'amendement que nous proposons
vise à supprimer la liste
des pays d'origine sûrs par essence
difficile à établir les demandeurs
d'asile seront véritablement protégée et
leurs droits certainement mieux
respectés merci alors monsieur le
rapporteur françois noël buffet vous
avez la parole pour l'avis de la
commission sur ces 11 amendements
merci monsieur le président sur
l'amendement 482 rectifié je ne refais
pas les commentaires que nous avons
faits sur les amendements précédent sur
cet article
et l'avis de la commission est un avis
défavorable pour le 234 c'est également
un avis défavorable pour les mêmes
raisons sur le 459 rectifié nous sommes
là aussi une demande de suppression d
examen des demandes d'asile en possible
prioritaires sauf qu'on précise en
l'occurrence aux amendements qu'il
s'agit de l'application des règles à
l'exception de celles nécessaires à
l'application du règlement dublin deux
avis défavorables en ce qui concerne le
235 rectifier la vie est également
défavorable
en ce qui concerne le 86 rectifié donc
on nous propose de supprimer les
dispositions permettant d'examiner les
demandes d'asile reposant sur une fraude
délibérée ou constitue un recours abusif
aux procédures d'asile je rappelle que
la commission exactement la commission
rappelle qu'il est essentiel de
conserver ce cas d'examen d'une demande
d'asile sur la procédure prioritaire
afin évidemment d'empêcher que les
demandes manifestions dilatoires de fass
échec à l'exécution d'une procédure
d'éloignement
c'est donc un avis défavorable sur le 86
rectifier la vie est identique pour le
236 rectifié est également identique
pour le 460
nous avons ensuite alors deux
amendements le 238 rectifié bis et le 16
mai je crois que vous avez appelé le 16
en premier cela dit l'explication est
identique
je voudrais préciser sur ces amendements
propose d'une part d'introduire dans
notre droit la définition de la notion
de pays d'origine sur telle que la
définit le droit communautaire et
d'autre part d'exclure du champ de la
procédure prioritaire les demandes
entrant dans le champ de la convention
de genève ou de la protection
subsidiaire
la commission des lois est favorable au
premier alinéa de ces amendements qui
introduirait dans notre droit la
définition du concept de pays sûrs
qu'ils figurent dans la directive du 1er
décembre 2005
en revanche en revanche donc je voudrais
insister pardon sur ce point sur ce
premier point sur deux premiers alinéas
cette définition nous paraît infiniment
plus explicite que celle qui est
aujourd'hui retenu par le par le texte
pourquoi parce qu en particulier lui la
notion de peines ou traitements
inhumains ou dégradants et cela permet
de prendre explicitement en compte les
mauvais traitements tels que les cas
d'excision ou les mariages forcés
en ce qui concerne par contre le
deuxième alinéa de cet amendement nous
sommes beaucoup plus commission est
beaucoup plus réservé on en comprend
bien la logique mais on craint toutefois
qu'il n'empêche de placer en procédure
prioritaire des étrangers qui
sollicitent l'asile de façon
manifestement dilatoire quelques heures
avant l'exécution de leur reconduction
la frontière par exemple même si les
demandes formulées noté circonstances
comporte des moyens valable ne sont pas
moins dilatoire en tout état de cause
en tout état de cause je voudrais
rappeler que l'examen d'une demande
d'asile selon la procédure prioritaire
ne fait pas obstacle à ce que l'ofpra
entendre le demandeur que les délais
d'examen sont toutefois réduits
néanmoins le demandeur en pro /
prioritaire ne peut pas être éloignés
tant que l'ofpra ne s'est pas prononcé
sur sa demande conformément aux
principes qui ont été posées par le
conseil constitutionnel donc la
commission a émis un avis favorable sur
l'alinéa 1er de l'amendement leurs 16 en
l'occurrence est défavorable sur
l'alinéa 2 de l'amendement 16 mai
également défavorable sur le ligne à
premier 238 rectifie lisse et donc
défavorable sur la ligne à deux
je voudrais préciser les choses de
rectifier les deux amendements 6 et les
auteurs en était d'accord je vous
propose
ah ouais pour votre part division
d'accord très bien continuer à excuser
moi c'est le rapporteur je vous en prie
monsieur président j'aurais voulu
apporter la précision suivante si nous
adoptons le premier alinéa de ces
amendements il doit impérativement venir
compléter l'article 75 du projet de loi
énonce y substituer en l'état l'article
75 modifie le quatrième alinéa de
l'article l
741 tiré 4 du code des étrangers avec le
premier alinéa de cet amendement
l'article 75 modifierait le deuxième
alinéa de l'article l 541 1-4 tels que
le rédige sites tels que réduit ses
amendements et le quatrième qui doit
rester rédigé dans la version qu'on
propose l'article 50 75 pierre dac ce
serait bien amusé bon excusez moi je
n'aurais pas dû dire ça bien sûr les
amendements 237 rectifier et sur le 477
rectifié bis la commission des lois a
émis également un avis défavorable pour
ces deux amendements mais je voudrais
préciser les choses
ces amendements proposent de supprimer
les dispositions du code des étrangers
relatives à la mention du pays d'origine
sur la notion de pays d'origine sûr est
issu du droit communautaire
le protocole annexé au traité
d'amsterdam du 2 octobre 97 prohibe en
principe les demandes d'asile entre
états membres de l'union européenne
selon la directive du 29 avril 2004
un pays est considéré comme sûr s'il
veille au respect des principes de
liberté de démocratie et de l'état de
droit ainsi que des droits de l'homme et
des libertés fondamentales
l'article 23 de la directive du 1er
décembre 2005 permet d'examiner les
demandes présentées par les
ressortissants de ces pays selon
effectivement la procédure prioritaire
trois remarques toutefois tout d'abord
cette notion de pays sûrs lundi qu'une
présomption de sécurité et ne fait pas
obstacle évidemment à une reconnaissance
de la qualité de réfugié par l'ofpra ou
par la cour nationale du droit d'asile
que par ailleurs la liste des pays de
sueur est établie par le conseil
d'administration de l'ofpra sous le
contrôle du juge administratif qui comme
le relèvent les auteurs de l'amendement
examine attentivement si les conditions
on réunit enfin et en toute hypothèse un
demandeur d'asile ressortissant d'un
pays d'origine sûrs ne peut pas être
éloignés avant que l'ofpra ne se soient
prononcés cette demande je l'expliqué
alain moment précédent l'utilisation
donc de cette notion est entouré de
nombreuses garanties c'est la raison
pour laquelle la commission jeu ces deux
amendements a émis un avis défavorable
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre
quel est l'avis du gouvernement sur ces
amendements monsieur le président un an
concernant l'amendement 482
rectificative 234 et 234 459
rectificative 235 rectificative 86
rectificatif et 236 rectificatif et 460
nous émettons un avis défavorable parce
que nous considérons que tous ces
amendements visent en réalité à
supprimer la procédure prioritaire alors
que la procédure privée prévue par la
loi on considère qu'elles assurent un
juste équilibre entre à la fois les
exigences du droit d'asile et la
nécessité de parer aux demandes d'asile
manifestement étrangères à une
problématique de protection concernant
les amendements numéro 16 et 238
rectificatif
le gouvernement maintient la rédaction
initiale est donc là dessus ne suit pas
l'avis de la commission parce qu'elles
considèrent qu effectivement la
définition d'un pays d'origine sûrs et
déjà prévue dans le code de l'entrée et
du séjour des étrangers et du droit
d'asile
il n'est aucunement nécessaire de
modifier cette définition ce d'autant
que cette définition est conforme au
droit communautaire selon la directive
du 1er décembre 2005
et s'agissant des amendements 235
rectificatif et 477 rectificative bis
qui vise en fait à supprimer la liste
des pays d'origine sur le gouvernement
considère que ce n'est pas acceptable un
souhait il souhaite conserver cette
liste et l'appli que ressortissants des
pays d'origine sur la procédure
prioritaire est d'ailleurs ce dispositif
est jugé conforme par le conseil
constitutionnel et est actuellement
autorisée par le droit communautaire
je vous remercie
nous allons passer à l'approbation de
ces différents amendements alors sur le
482 rectifié qui a été présenté par le
groupe socialiste deux avis défavorables
y at il une demande d'explications de
vote qui est pour adopter c'est
d'amendements qui est contre il n'est
pas adoptée sur le 234,2 avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement je considère que c'est le
même vote
c'est le même vote il n'est pas adopté
il en est de même pour le 459 rectifié
qui a été présenté par le groupe
socialiste deux avis défavorables de la
commission et du gouvernement c'est le
même bord il n'est pas adopté
malama sacile 235 rectifié bis deux avis
défavorables selman vote
il n'est pas adopté ensuite nous avions
trois amendements identiques qui on est
bien qu'ils n'ont pas eu les faveurs ni
de la commission ni du gouvernement
je considère que ce sont les mêmes votes
ils ne sont pas adoptées et par contre
alors sur le 16 et le 238 rectifié biz
je rappelle que le gouvernement a mis un
avis défavorable sur ces deux
amendements
par contre la commission a souhaité agir
par division donné un avis favorable sur
la première partie est par contre sur la
deuxième partie un avis défavorable
y at il une demande d'explications de
vote alors madame borvo vous m'aviez
demandé la parole et amina boumédiene
thiery
madame la présidente vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président oui nous
avons bien entendu ce qu'a dit notre
rapporteur et bien évidemment nous
sommes
nous pouvons actes et qu'il est
favorable au premier paragraphe
mais je veux dire que le quatrième le
deuxième paragraphe plutôt qui concerne
le quatrième alinéa de l'article que
nous souhaitons a ajouté me paraît quand
même important parce que il précise
quand même que l'examen individuel
pourra être pris en compte de façon
sérieuse et pourra bénéficier à un
certain nombre de personnes qui ne sont
pas issus de pays d'origine considérés
comme non sûre et qui pourtant est ce ne
sera pas une trace électif je veux dire
pourquoi je moi je trouve quand même
regrettable que notre beau pays de
france accepte que l'asile soit
simplement possible pour des personnes
venant de pays non sur vous savez nous
sommes énormes guilly d'avoir accueilli
beaucoup d'artistes écrivains cinéastes
américains au moment du maccarthysme et
donc voyez là si on se réfère à cette
période et à ce que on entend
aujourd'hui par pays sur on voit bien
que ça ne fait pas ça ne permet pas de
répondre de même
victor hugo s'est exilé à gers est bon
que quand n'aurait-il était de la france
pays sans doute sur aux yeux de la
grande bretagne à l'époque
voyez c'est je crois que il faut penser
à cela quand on discute allègrement de
liste de pays surnom sûr je pense que le
droit d'asile quoi qu'il en soit doit
rester quand même quelque chose de qui
mérite un examen individuel parce que
intel ne pourra évidemment pas prétendre
peut-être à l'asile parce qu'en réalité
il essaiera parents billets quelconque
de d'en bénéficier et d'autres que vous
mettrez dans la même catégorie sont
empêchés d'exercer leur métier
je pense à nombre d'avocats tunisiens
qui ne pouvait pas exercer leur
profession
jusqu'à une période très récente aux
yeux du gouvernement français la tunisie
était considérée comme un pays sûr or il
ne pouvait pas travailler parce qu'ils
étaient des opposants et qu'ils étaient
pourtant avocats professeurs voyez c'est
des notions quand même
je trouve qu'ils méritent faire bien
attention et en plus je constate que les
pays européens n'arrivent pas à se
mettre d'accord sur une liste
alors nous avons promu cette façon de
faire mais ça mériterait qu'on y
réfléchisse donc notre deuxième alinéa
qui permet quand même d'être de dire qu'
on ne peut pas considérer comme un
recours abusif aux produits le la
demande d'asile pendant des années
d'étrangers qui évoque des circonstances
susceptibles de lui permettre de se voir
reconnaître le cachet sur la qualité de
réfugié ou la protection subsidiaire ça
mais quand même un peu plus ses points
sur les i pour dire que une personne à
l'individu parce que il est empêché dans
son pays que peut-être nous considérons
comme sur un moment donné en tout cas
aller les pouvoirs qui décide à chaque
moment qui est sûr qu'il n'est pas sûr
et bien a le droit
oui de pouvoir exercé par exemple son
talent sa profession sa profession
ailleurs est tout simplement son métier
parce qu'il ya aussi des ouvriers qui
sont dans cette même situation bien
monsieur le président vous avez souhaité
prendre la parole sur le palier dans si
la commission pense que la définition du
pays d'origine sur doit faire l'objet de
précisions conformément à l'évolution du
droit
c'est extrêmement subtil mélange borvo
parce qu'en fait compte votre quatrième
millénaire détruits il détruit la
procédure prioritaire et on revient par
un autre biais à ce que vous avez
défendu ce qui est tout à fait logique
alors il faut quand même pas nous on dit
d'accord ce que vos amendements sont
extrêmement bien construit mais si on
adoptait l'intégralité en fin de compte
tout ce qu'on a dit sur la procédure
prioritaire tombe donc on est logique
la commission c'est pour ça que le
président que là le vote par division
n'est d'accord pour là des fissures
dépôts du pays d'origine sur la
commission et on n'est pas d'accord bien
sûr sur le quatrième à lider parce que
tout ce qu'on a dit sur la procédure
prioritaire en fait vous la détruisez
c'est très bien mais on peut pas
d'accord c'est tout ce que je sais c'est
pour que ce soient parfaitement claires
pour tous nos collègues
demande alima boumédiene thiery vous
avez la parole
non mais comme madame la présidente
vient de dire beaucoup de choses avec
lesquelles je suis un accord je resterai
simplement sur la proposition qui nous
est faite et je considère que c'est déjà
intéressant de faire une vote par
division permettant d'accepter donc la
première partie et la seconde partie qui
me semble aussi importante
mais tant pis s'il faut gagner quelque
chose autant gagné déjà la première
partie merci bien
alors on a tous compris qu'il y avait
une unanimité il y aura deux autres il y
à une unanimité qui se dégage pour la
deuxième phrase du deuxième point
première
voilà la première partie de l'amendement
et puis sur le quatrième en voilà allez
qui est pour adopter la première partie
et bien cette première partie est adopté
à l'unanimité
qui est pour adopter il ya une
abstention
excusez moi jacques gauthier j'ai été
inattentif alors c'est l'unanimité des
exprimés bien aller le quatrième le
quatrièmement la deuxième partie qui est
pour adopter cette deuxième partie qui
est contre elle n'est pas adoptée et
donc conformément à la déclaration du
rapporteur la première partie de ces
amendements sincère avant le premier
alinéa de l'article 75
l'alinéa 2 de l'article est maintenu je
vous remercie
alors nous poursuivons avec deux
amendements identiques qui étaient
soumis à l'approbation dont je rappelle
deux avis défavorables de la queue
mission et du gouvernement le 237
rectifié d'eliane assassi et le 477
rectifié bis de run and care brown qui
est pour adopter ces deux amendements
identiques
ouais en fait ils tombent ils sont
tombés je vous remercie et maintenant le
vote sur l'article je réfléchis à voix
haute voyez l'article 75 qui est pour
l'adopter ainsi amendée qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté ainsi
amendé nous passons l'examen de
l'article 75 bis a donc nous avons trois
amendements identiques de suppressions
qui peuvent faire l'objet d'une
discussion commune
alors qu'est-ce qui nous présente ces
notions du verre noir qui nous présente
l'amendement numéro saint louis
duvernois vous avez la parole le
président madame le ministre mes chers
collègues alors que la loi relative
à l'action extérieure de l'état prévu
une double tutelle des ministres des
affaires étrangères et de l'enseignement
supérieur sur le nouvel établissement
public campusfrance cet article issu
d'un amendement adopté par l'assemblée
nationale vise à modifier le texte
adopté par le parlement l'été dernier en
ajoutant la tutelle du ministre chargé
de l'immigration sur cet établissement
ce qui aboutirait à une triple tutelle
je rappelle que la multiplicité des
tutelles est par principe à proscrire
afin de simplifier les relations de
l'établissement public avec l'état et de
renforcer son pilotage stratégique
cette question de la tutelle sur le
nouvel établissement public campus
france avait été longuement étudié je le
rappelle au sein de la commission des
affaires étrangères
saisie au fond et de la commission de la
culture saisie pour avis dans le cadre
de l'examen du projet de loi relatif à
l'action extérieure de l'état
les deux commissions sénatoriales
avaient estimé qu'une tutelle partagée
entre trois ministères ne serait pas
gage d'efficacité et pourrait contribuer
un déficit de pilotage stratégique sur
le nouvel opérateur
dans cette logique il me semble
souhaitable dans un souci de garder et
d'efficacité de limiter les ministères
de tutelle aux deux ministères
directement et significativement
impliquée dans la définition des
orientations stratégiques la gouvernance
et le financement de l'établissement les
compétences du ministère de l'intérieur
en matière de visas ne saurait en outre
elle seule constituer une raison valable
lui conférer la tutelle de
l'établissement
en effet une proportion importante des
étudiants étrangers en france notamment
les étudiants originaires de l'espace de
schengen échappe à la procédure des
visas qui n'est pas en vigueur avec leur
pays d'origine
je vous propose donc mes chers collègues
par cet amendement de supprimer la
tutelle du ministère de l'intérieur sur
campus france et de revenir aux
dispositions que nous avions adopté en
juillet 2010 dans un climat consensuel
si jean duvernoy et le président jarekji
a le même amendement de suppression
le président madame le ministre mais
chaque collègue louis duvernois revient
de motiver l'opportunité de cet
amendement je vous avoue que avec mon
collègue adrien gouteyron nous nous
sommes interrogés sur l'opportunité
d'inscrire dans le texte sur
l'immigration
une telle disposition confiant la
tutelle de campusfrance au ministère de
l'intérieur chargé de l'immigration je
parle sous le contrôle président et des
membres de la commission des lois du
rapporteur nous sommes à la limite d'un
d'un cavalier par rapport au contenu de
ce texte
adrien gouteyron et moi même avons
déposé cet amendement parce que dans le
cadre des travaux de contrôle de la
commission des finances
nous avions sollicité de la cour des
comptes une enquête sur l'association
égide qui était je le rappelle une des
structures dont est issu campus france
et à l'occasion de cette audition nous
étions interrogés sur l'opportunité
d'une
triple tutelle et je veux dire que le
débat que nous avions eu à cette
occasion le 13 octobre 2010 avait été
parfaitement clair et la conclusion
était qu'il fallait s'en tenir à la
double tutelle issu de la loi de 2010 et
rien d'autre je ne reviens pas sur les
arguments présentés par louis duvernois
ils sont les nôtres et donc nous
demandons au sénat de supprimer cet
article 75 bis à bord qui est ce qu'il
nous présente c'est richard yung qui
nous présente l'amendement 464 est
identique de suppression merci monsieur
le président c'est effectivement un
amendement identique
je rappelle que l'opérateur campus
france a été créée par la loi du 27
juillet 27 juillet 2010 il ya six mois
sept mois au rendez compte la qualité du
travail législatif que l'on fait quelle
instabilité
monsieur le président quelle instabilité
on débat avec toute la sagesse du sénat
au mois de juillet on a un long débat
sur le problème de la tutelle et puis
six mois après voilà un objet législatif
non identifié qui vient se poser sur nos
textes franchement c'est quand même
l'illustration de la mauvaise qualité de
notre travail et de la mauvaise
organisation du gouvernement à la
matière je le dis monsieur le président
si on en avait moins et mieux faire on
se porterait mieux et le pays se porte
très bien
voilà c'est un amendement qui en plus
alors lui c'est un vrai cavalier puisque
c'est le député jean françois mancel
alors je sais pas pourquoi monsieur
jean-françois avance elle s'est occupée
s'est occupé de multiplier les tutelles
de campus france enfin tout le monde
sait que une tutelle
savard deux tutelles difficile trois
tutelles c'est fini 1
y'a pas il n'y a pas besoin de sortir de
lâcher c'est pour savoir ça voilà oui
c'est peut-être un proverbe auvergnats
comme vous dites voilà donc je reprends
pas les autres arguments qui ont été
excellemment développé par peut-être que
peut-être le seul président voilà donc
pour ces raisons là nous rejoignons les
autres proposition de suppression
voici le rapporteur il favorable de la
commission favorable
favorables eux non mais favorable madame
la ministre monsieur le président
d'abord re situer un peu le contexte si
lors de l'examen en première lecture de
ce projet de loi à l'assemblée nationale
que la commission des lois par la voix
de jean luc warsmann a introduit
effectivement cette disposition pour
placer la tutelle de campus france sous
l'autorité du ministère de l'immigration
alors cette proposition pourrait se
justifier par le fait que le ministère
de l'immigration a en charge la
politique d'entrée de ces jouets
l'exercice d'une activité
professionnelle et en l'occurrence a
inclus les étudiants étrangers puisque
le ministère chargé des migrations aura
effectivement à traiter des questions
notamment s'agissant des visas et des
séjours et là dessus il aura un rôle
déterminant à jouer
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que cette proposition a été formulée
mais pour autant le gouvernement s'en
remet à la sagesse de la haute assemblée
bien christian cointat vous avez la
parole pour explication de vote y at il
d'autres demandes de parole christian
paul un résident à la ministre je
pourrais très bref mes chers collègues
puisque madame la ministre mr la sagesse
de l'assemblée
mais j'en profite quand même pour dire
qu'il faut faire très attention avec les
multiplications de tutelle là je rejoins
tout à fait richard yung une tutelle
on sait qui est responsable à partir de
deux ça commence à se déliter à 3 ne
comprends plus rien deux tutelles c'est
vraiment la multiplication des tutelles
c'est la dilution de la responsabilité
mais c'est là aussi la multiplication
des blocages
voilà pourquoi il faut éviter c'est
multiplication et donc je voterai
l'amendement les amendements de
suppression bien alors nous avons des
avis favorables de la part de la
commission
ensuite de sagesse du gouvernement y at
il d'autres demandes d'explications de
vote qui est pour adopter ces trois
amendements de suppression et bien là
c'est l'avis unanime des présents
l'article 75 bis à est supprimé je vous
remercie
nous passons à l'examen de l'article 75
bis riches à lyon que vous avez souhaité
prendre la parole
merci monsieur le président oui parce
que c'est un article important le je
souhaite profiter de l'examen de cet
article pour condamner stigmatiser une
nouvelle fois la remise en cause de
l'aide médicale d'état
len la création par la loi de finances
de 2011 ou pour 2011 d'un droit d'entrée
annuel parra du bénéficiaire de la msp
est injuste dangereuse et
contreproductive à la fois sur le plan
médical et sur le plan financier
présenté comme des mesures d'économies à
faire des économies
rgpp s'interroger pp les restrictions
d'accès à la hem risque de produire
l'effet inverse à savoir un
alourdissement des dépenses cette
crainte a d'ailleurs été récemment
formulées par des gens extrêmement
sérieux qui sont les inspecte que sont
les inspections générales des finances
et des affaires sociales l'ijf et l'igas
au terme d'une enquête
d'après cette enquête la mise en place
d'un droit d'entrée qui est censée
rapporter 6 millions d'euros par an
risque de conduire à de lourds effets
pervers sans avoir d'effets de
responsabilisation des assurés je cite
les deux inspections générales sans se
prononcer directement sur le forfait de
30 euros
les inspecteurs de l'igas ont souligné
que toute contribution même modeste
dissuadera certains malades se faire
soigner ce qui multipliera les recours
tardif
à l'hôpital nettement plus coûteux si
10% des malades retardent leur prise en
charge les dépenses de soin
s'alourdiront de 20 millions d'euros
soit trois fois plus que les économies
attendues
enfin et je regrette que le président de
la commission des finances nous ait
quittés
je regrette que notre amendement 465
n'est pas été déclarée a été déclarée
pardon est recevable en fonction de
l'article 40 de la constitution qui est
une sorte d'épée de damoclès qui nous
tombe dessus sans que l'on sache ni
comment ni pourquoi
d'après le président la suppression du
droit d'entrée aurait risqué d'étendre
le champ des bénéficiaires de la m nous
quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette séance nous
reviendrons bien entendu sur le projet
loi immigration dans nos éditions de 19h
et de 22 heures
merci de votre fidélité très belle
journée à tous sur public sénat